bentornati a capire le informazioni e il calcolo quantistico mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico per l'educazione a IBM Quantum
questa è la tredicesima lezione della serie ed è la prima lezione della quarta e ultima unità che riguarda la correzione degli errori quantistici
il Quantum Computing ha il potenziale per abilitare soluzioni efficienti a task computazionali per cui
algoritmi classici efficienti non sono noti e possibilmente non esistono ci sono tuttavia sfide molto significative che
dovranno essere superate se vogliamo implementare il tipo di calcoli quantistici su larga scala che speriamo un giorno saranno
possibili il cuore del problema è che le informazioni quantistiche sono estremamente fragili puoi letteralmente rovinarle semplicemente
osservandole e quindi per funzionare correttamente i computer quantistici devono isolare le informazioni quantistiche che
memorizzano dall'ambiente circostante in modo estremo ma allo stesso tempo il computer quantistico stesso deve fornirci un
controllo molto preciso su queste informazioni quantistiche e ciò include una corretta inizializzazione operazioni unitarie accurate e affidabili
e ovviamente la capacità di eseguire misurazioni per poter ottenere i risultati del
calcolo c'è chiaramente una certa tensione tra questi requisiti e nei primi giorni del Quantum Computing c'erano alcuni che ritenevano che la fragilità
delle informazioni quantistiche e la loro suscettibilità sia alle imprecisioni che al rumore ambientale avrebbero alla fine
reso il Quantum Computing impossibile oggi c'è poca perplessità sul fatto che costruire un
computer quantistico accurato affidabile e su larga scala sia una sfida monumentale ma abbiamo uno strumento fondamentale per aiutarci in questa impresa che porta la maggior parte
delle persone esperte del campo a essere ottimiste riguardo al Quantum Computing su larga scala che un giorno diventerà realtà e quello strumento è la correzione degli errori quantistici
per le prossime quattro lezioni discuteremo la correzione degli errori quantistici con focus sui
fondamentali in questa lezione daremo un primo sguardo alla correzione degli errori quantistici incluso uno dei primissimi codici di correzione degli errori quantistici
scoperti il codice Shore a 9 qubit e discuteremo anche un altro concetto fondamentale nel Quantum
error correction noto come discretizzazione degli errori nelle lezioni successive dell'unità vedremo costruzioni di codici di correzione degli errori quantistici più sofisticati e alla fine migliori
e discuteremo anche il problema del calcolo quantistico su informazioni quantistiche codificate usando
componenti computazionali che non sono essi stessi perfetti e inclini agli errori ecco una breve panoramica della
lezione inizieremo discutendo i codici a ripetizione classici che sono forse il tipo più semplice e basilare di
codici di correzione degli errori classici i codici a ripetizione classici non sono codici particolarmente buoni secondo gli standard della
teoria della codifica classica almeno non da soli ma va bene qui puntiamo alla semplicità e in particolare
daremo un'occhiata al codice di correzione degli errori classico più semplice che si possa immaginare che useremo poi come base per un semplice esempio
di codice di correzione degli errori quantistici quell'esempio è il codice Shore a 9 qubit di cui discuteremo in dettaglio
inclusa una descrizione del codice stesso nonché le procedure per codificare i qubit usando questo codice rilevare errori su qubit codificati e
correggere quegli errori e nella terza parte della lezione discuteremo la discretizzazione degli errori che ci consente di pensare ad errori arbitrari su
qubit che in linea di principio formano un continuum di possibilità in termini discreti riducendo essenzialmente gli errori ai
cosiddetti bit flip e phase flip prima di entrare nei dettagli tecnici della correzione degli errori quantistici vale la pena
prendersi un momento per considerare la necessità della correzione degli errori quantistici nonché della correzione degli errori classici
come ho suggerito all'inizio della lezione i computer quantistici sono altamente suscettibili agli errori a causa
della fragilità delle informazioni quantistiche in particolare le interazioni indesiderate con l'ambiente o in altre
parole con il resto del mondo possono disturbare le informazioni quantistiche queste interazioni indesiderate possono causare la decoerenza dove le informazioni
essenzialmente fuoriescono nell'ambiente causando un comportamento delle informazioni memorizzate dal computer quantistico sempre più
classico è anche di fondamentale importanza riconoscere che le operazioni quantistiche possono essere eseguite solo con una precisione limitata
per esempio potremmo voler eseguire un particolare gate quantistico su un qubit ma poiché i dispositivi fisici non sono
mai perfetti ciò che implementiamo effettivamente potrebbe essere solo un'approssimazione di quel gate il che potrebbe non essere un grosso problema per un
singolo gate ma se la nostra intenzione è eseguire migliaia o milioni di gate quantistici queste piccole imprecisioni inizieranno ad
accumularsi e quando il calcolo è finito potremmo trovarci con uno stato molto diverso da quello che ci
aspettavamo quindi questa è una fonte di errori piuttosto diversa ma è certamente una che non possiamo
ignorare le persone studiano i codici di correzione degli errori classici da quasi un secolo e questi codici hanno molte applicazioni tra cui nella
trasmissione e nello storage di informazioni ma poiché i componenti del calcolo classico sono così affidabili non abbiamo effettivamente
bisogno della correzione degli errori per costruire computer classici ora potrebbe essere che la correzione degli errori non sia effettivamente necessaria
per costruire computer quantistici affidabili su larga scala per esempio l'idea principale alla base del Quantum
Computing topologico è che potrebbe essere possibile costruire sistemi quantistici robusti intrinsecamente protetti dal rumore a causa
delle proprietà topologiche dei sistemi ma non sappiamo se questo sarà possibile ed è abbastanza diffusamente creduto
che la correzione degli errori sarà probabilmente essenziale in una forma o nell'altra per il Quantum Computing su larga scala ora discuteremo i codici a
ripetizione classici che formano la base del nostro primo codice di correzione degli errori quantistici il codice Shore a 9 qubit che
vedremo tra poco i codici a ripetizione sono esempi estremamente basilari di codici di correzione degli errori
l'idea è che possiamo proteggere i bit dagli errori semplicemente ripetendo ogni bit un certo numero di volte in particolare diamo un'occhiata al
codice a ripetizione a tre bit qui codifichiamo un bit in tre semplicemente ripetendo il bit tre volte quindi
zero viene codificato come 000 e uno viene codificato come 111 ovviamente se non va niente storto possiamo
facilmente distinguere le due possibilità ma se c'era un errore e uno dei bit si è invertito diciamo
che uno zero diventa un uno o un uno diventa uno zero possiamo ancora capire qual era il bit originale
vedendo quale dei due valori binari appare due volte equivalentemente possiamo decodificare calcolando il valore di maggioranza
o in altre parole il valore binario che appare più frequentemente e non è difficile vedere che
se abbiamo al massimo un errore di inversione del bit allora la decodifica sarà corretta ovviamente se due bit si invertono o se
tutti e tre i bit si invertono non funzionerà e otterremo il valore sbagliato quando decodifichiamo e questa è una proprietà generale
che ogni codice di correzione degli errori possiede potresti essere in grado di correggere alcuni errori ma non potrai mai correggere tutti gli errori e alla fine si tratta
di diminuire la probabilità di un errore piuttosto che garantire la correttezza il che in genere non è
possibile come esempio di una situazione in cui possiamo diminuire la probabilità di sbagliare supponiamo che il
nostro obiettivo sia comunicare un singolo bit a un destinatario ipotetico e per farlo siamo in grado di trasmettere bit attraverso un cosiddetto
canale binario simmetrico che inverte ogni bit trasmesso attraverso di esso indipendentemente con una certa probabilità
P quindi con probabilità 1 meno P il destinatario riceverà qualunque bit intendevamo inviare ma con probabilità P
il bit si inverte e il destinatario riceve il valore opposto a quello che abbiamo inviato quindi se non usiamo il codice a
ripetizione e invece inviamo semplicemente qualunque bit abbiamo in mente attraverso il canale il destinatario riceverà il bit sbagliato con
probabilità p d'altra parte se prima codifichiamo il bit che vogliamo inviare usando il codice a ripetizione a tre bit e
poi inviamo ciascuno dei tre bit della codifica attraverso il canale allora ciascuno di essi si inverte con probabilità P quindi
le possibilità di un'inversione del bit sono ora maggiori perché ci sono ora tre bit che potrebbero potenzialmente invertirsi invece di uno
ma se al massimo uno dei bit si inverte allora il destinatario sarà in grado di decodificare correttamente quindi otterremo un errore dopo
la decodifica solo se due o più bit si invertono durante la trasmissione e non è troppo difficile calcolare che questo accade con
probabilità 3 * P^2 - 2 * P^3 per valori di P più piccoli di 1/12
questo porta a una diminuzione della probabilità che il destinatario finisca con il bit sbagliato ci sarà ancora una possibilità di errore in questo caso ma il
codice diminuisce la probabilità di questo e se volessi ridurre ulteriormente la probabilità potresti farlo usando un
codice diverso inclusa ma non limitata alla possibilità di usare un codice a ripetizione in cui il bit codificato viene ripetuto
più di tre volte per valori di P superiori a 1/12 tra l'altro il codice in realtà
peggiora le cose nel senso che aumenta la probabilità che il destinatario riceva il bit sbagliato quindi certamente non useremmo questo codice in quella
situazione il codice a ripetizione a tre bit è un codice di correzione degli errori classico ma possiamo anche considerare cosa succede se
proviamo a usarlo per proteggere i qubit dagli errori non è un codice di correzione degli errori quantistici molto buono come vedremo
può correggere alcuni errori ma rende altri errori più probabili tuttavia è il primo passo verso il codice Shore
quindi vediamo come funziona per i qubit prima per chiarire quando ci riferiamo al codice a ripetizione a 3 bit usato
per i qubit quello che abbiamo in mente è una codifica di un qubit come mostrato sullo schermo dove Alpha 0 più beta 1 viene
codificato come Alpha 000 più beta 111 o in altre parole lo stato della base standard
viene ripetuto tre volte nota in particolare che questo non è la stessa cosa di ripetere lo stato quantistico tre volte come in un dato
stato quantistico s codificato come s tensore s tensore s il che non è una codifica che saremmo in grado di
implementare per uno stato quantistico sconosciuto s per il teorema del no-cloning la codifica di cui stiamo parlando
d'altra parte è molto facilmente implementabile ecco un circuit quantistico molto semplice che lo fa usando due qubit workspace inizializzati e due
gate controlled-NOT ora supponiamo che si verifichi un errore dopo che la codifica è stata
eseguita e in particolare supponiamo che un'operazione polyX o in altre parole un'inversione del bit avvenga su uno dei
qubit e in questa figura è il qubit centrale naturalmente questo non è l'unico tipo di errore che potrebbe verificarsi e potresti
obiettare all'idea che un errore abbia la forma di questa perfetta operazione unitaria ma torneremo su questo più avanti nella lezione e per ora possiamo
semplicemente pensarci come un esempio ecco lo stato risultante è lo stesso della codifica originale tranne per il fatto
che il bit centrale all'interno di ogni ket è stato invertito ovviamente possiamo vederlo dalle espressioni matematiche per lo stato
ma supponiamo di avere solo i tre qubit e che sospettassimo che si potesse essere verificata un'inversione del bit ma non sapessimo quale qubit potrebbe essere stato
colpito un modo per capire se si è verificata un'inversione del bit sarebbe eseguire una misurazione della base standard ed esaminare il risultato in questo caso vedremmo
010 oppure 110 con probabilità dipendenti da Alpha e beta e in entrambi i casi la nostra conclusione
sarebbe che il bit centrale si è invertito ma purtroppo ciò rovina lo stato quantistico originale e questo stato
potrebbe essere prezioso per noi dopotutto il punto è proprio proteggere questo stato quantistico quindi questa non è una buona
opzione quello che possiamo fare invece è usare il circuit quantistico mostrato qui sullo schermo dove inseriamo lo stato codificato
nei primi tre qubit fondamentalmente quello che fa il circuit è calcolare la parità degli stati della
base standard per i due qubit superiori nonché per i due qubit inferiori della codifica e questo rivelerà la
posizione dell'inversione del bit in particolare in questo caso otterremo il risultato uno per entrambi questi controlli di parità e da
quelle informazioni possiamo concludere che è il bit centrale ad essere diverso dagli altri due quindi è evidentemente quello che si è
invertito e crucialmente questo non causa il collasso dello stato quindi ora abbiamo la possibilità di provare a correggere questa inversione del
bit in modo da poter eventualmente decodificare e recuperare il nostro stato originale torneremo alla correzione
tra un momento ma prima consideriamo brevemente le altre possibilità per un errore di inversione del bit se invece l'errore di inversione del bit
si è verificato sul qubit inferiore o sinistro otterremmo il risultato uno zero leggendo dal basso verso l'alto e di nuovo
lo stato non cambierebbe e se l'inversione del bit fosse avvenuta sul qubit superiore allora l'output sarebbe
01 e ancora una volta lo stato non cambia e tra l'altro se non c'era nessun
errore di inversione del bit allora il risultato della misurazione è 00 e ancora una volta lo stato esce invariato
quindi riassumiamo tutto ciò nella forma di una tabella dove elenchiamo ciascuno dei possibili stati che otteniamo da al massimo un'inversione del bit i risultati della misurazione
che chiamiamo sindrome nel contesto della correzione degli errori e la correzione che dobbiamo fare per recuperare la
codifica originale se non c'era errore la sindrome è 00 e non è necessario fare nulla per correggere lo
stato se il qubit inferiore o più a sinistra ha subito un'inversione del bit la sindrome è 10 e la correzione appropriata
è applicare un gate X al qubit inferiore o più a sinistra e gli altri due casi sono
simili quindi se applichiamo la correzione appropriata in base alla sindrome allora saremo certi di recuperare la
codifica originale in tutti e quattro i casi ancora una volta stiamo considerando solo la possibilità che si sia verificato al massimo un
errore di inversione del bit questo non funzionerebbe correttamente se si invertissero due o tre bit e non abbiamo nemmeno considerato la
possibilità di altri errori ora consideriamo un diverso tipo di errore nel contesto quantistico le inversioni del
bit non sono gli unici errori di cui dobbiamo preoccuparci per esempio dobbiamo preoccuparci anche delle inversioni di fase
o semplicemente phase flip in breve che sono descritte dai gate Z o equivalentemente dalle operazioni Pauli Z
purtroppo il codice a ripetizione a tre bit fallisce completamente nel rilevare le inversioni di fase per esempio supponendo che codifichiamo
un qubit usando il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit come prima e si verifica un errore di phase flip sul qubit
centrale otterremo lo stato mostrato sullo schermo che è esattamente la codifica che avremmo ottenuto se si fosse verificata una
phase flip sul qubit originale prima che lo codificassimo e quindi se eseguiamo lo stesso
circuit di prima per provare a rilevare un errore otterremmo la sindrome 00 che suggerisce erroneamente che non si sono verificati errori
quindi il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit funziona per al massimo una inversione del bit ma non riesce a rilevare gli errori di phase flip in
effetti in realtà peggiora le cose in un certo senso perché ora abbiamo tre volte più qubit che potrebbero potenzialmente subire inversioni di fase
abbiamo osservato che il codice a ripetizione a tre bit è completamente ignaro degli errori di phase flip quindi non sembra
essere molto utile per gestire questo tipo di errore ma in realtà possiamo modificare il codice a ripetizione a tre bit in modo che
rilevi gli errori di phase flip e ora spiegherò come si può fare ecco il circuit originale per
codificare un qubit usando il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit e il modo in cui lo modificheremo è molto semplice applichiamo semplicemente un
gate Hadamard a ciascun qubit della codifica un gate Hadamard trasforma uno stato zero in uno stato più e uno
stato uno in uno stato meno quindi l'effetto netto è che otteniamo lo stato mostrato sullo schermo dove ket
più-più-più e ket meno-meno-meno sono notazioni abbreviate per il tensore di tre stati più o tre stati meno
un errore di phase flip o in altre parole un gate Z trasforma gli stati più in stati meno e gli stati meno in
stati più quindi questa codifica sarà utile per rilevare e correggere gli errori di phase flip e per farlo possiamo
modificare il circuit di rilevamento degli errori di prima nel modo seguente ecco il circuit di prima e quello che faremo è
semplicemente inserire gate Hadamard sia all'inizio che alla fine come mostrato sullo schermo
l'idea è molto semplice i primi tre gate Hadamard trasformano gli stati più e meno di nuovo in stati zero e uno gli
stessi controlli di parità di prima hanno luogo e poi il secondo layer di gate Hadamard ci riporta alla nostra
codifica un altro modo di pensarci è che stiamo fondamentalmente trasformando gli errori di phase flip in errori di bit flip coniugando per operazioni Hadamard
possiamo tra l'altro semplificare leggermente il circuit questo circuit qui è completamente equivalente
e puoi verificarlo tu stesso se sei incline quindi se inseriamo il nostro qubit codificato in questo circuit assumendo
che non si siano verificati errori di phase flip otteniamo la sindrome 00 indicando che non ci sono state inversioni di fase
e se abbiamo un errore di phase flip sul qubit superiore diciamo allora i più e meno più a destra si invertono
e questo si traduce in una diversa sindrome di errore 01 in questo caso che identifica la posizione della phase flip proprio come
abbiamo fatto per l'inversione del bit e possiamo quindi correggerla applicando un gate Z al qubit superiore e la situazione
è simile per gli errori di phase flip su uno qualsiasi degli altri due qubit quindi possiamo in effetti rilevare e
correggere fino a un errore di phase flip usando questo codice ma purtroppo come potresti aver intuito ora non possiamo più
correggere gli errori di bit flip non è però tutto perduto perché possiamo in effetti combinare questi due codici
insieme per ottenere un codice che possa correggere sia le inversioni del bit che le inversioni di fase e in effetti sarà in grado di
correggere qualsiasi errore su un singolo qubit è giunto il momento di discutere il codice Shore a 9 qubit che è un codice di
correzione degli errori quantistici che possiamo ottenere combinando insieme i due codici che abbiamo appena visto ovvero il codice a ripetizione a tre bit
che ci consente di correggere un singolo errore di bit flip e la versione modificata di quel codice che ci consente di correggere un singolo errore di phase flip
per essere più precisi il codice Shore a 9 qubit è il codice che otteniamo concatenando i due codici il che significa
che prima applichiamo una codifica che codifica un qubit in tre e poi applichiamo l'altra codifica a ciascuno dei
tre qubit separatamente quindi otterremo nove qubit in totale possiamo esprimere questo nella forma di
un diagramma di circuit nel modo seguente prima applicheremo la versione modificata del codice a ripetizione a 3 bit
che rileva gli errori di phase flip e poi codificheremo ciascuno dei qubit risultanti indipendentemente usando il codice a
ripetizione a 3 bit originale quindi se restringiamo un po' questo circuit per fare un po' più di spazio possiamo
specificare il codice in termini leggermente diversi descrivendo come i due stati della base standard per il nostro qubit originale vengono
codificati e una volta che sappiamo questo possiamo determinare per linearità come un vettore di stato qubit arbitrario viene
codificato quindi questo è il codice Shore a 9 qubit e l'idea è che uno dei codici ci consente di correggere gli errori di phase flip
e l'altro codice ci consente di correggere gli errori di bit flip e come vedremo questo implica in effetti che possiamo
correggere un errore arbitrario su un singolo qubit ora vediamo come possiamo rilevare e correggere gli errori usando il codice Shore a 9 qubit
partendo dagli errori di bit flip che si chiamano anche errori X ecco il circuit che esegue
la codifica e solo per rendere più facile parlarne pensiamo ai nove qubit che otteniamo da questo codice come
raggruppati in tre blocchi di tre qubit dove ogni blocco rappresenta la codifica che otteniamo applicando il
secondo passo di codifica che è il codice a ripetizione a 3 bit ordinario questo si chiama codice interno in
questo contesto mentre il codice esterno è il codice usato per il primo passo di codifica che in questo caso è la versione modificata
del codice a ripetizione a tre bit che funziona per gli errori di phase flip per correggere gli errori di bit flip possiamo
semplicemente trattare ciascuno dei blocchi separatamente ogni blocco è una codifica di un qubit usando il codice a ripetizione a tre bit
e quel codice protegge dagli errori di bit flip supponiamo prima che si verifichi un errore X su uno qualsiasi dei qubit
come il qubit centrale nel blocco centrale se controlliamo indipendentemente ciascuno dei blocchi per errori di bit flip e
correggiamo eventuali errori che troviamo allora questo errore verrà corretto e la codifica originale verrà
recuperata in effetti potremmo anche avere più errori X e correggerli in questo modo a condizione che gli errori siano
in blocchi separati se avessimo due o tre errori X in un singolo blocco avremmo dei problemi ma
finché c'è al massimo un errore X per blocco il codice interno li coglierà e saremo in grado di recuperare lo stato codificato originale
quindi correggere gli errori di bit flip è una questione abbastanza semplice per questo codice dobbiamo anche considerare gli errori di phase flip
o in altre parole gli errori Z questa volta non è del tutto chiaro cosa dobbiamo fare perché il codice esterno è quello
che corregge gli errori di phase flip ma non possiamo rilevare e correggerli direttamente perché il codice interno è in qualche modo
nel mezzo ma vedremo come farlo a breve per capire meglio come funzionano gli errori X e Z
e gli effetti che hanno all'interno dei circuit quantistici è utile osservare alcune semplici relazioni tra questi errori e i gate
CNOT e questo sarà utile anche in una lezione successiva iniziamo con gli errori X
o gate X e come si relazionano ai gate CNOT se applichiamo un gate X al
qubit target di un CNOT e poi applichiamo il CNOT allora è equivalente a scambiare l'ordine e fare prima il CNOT
d'altra parte se applichiamo un gate X al qubit di controllo di un CNOT e poi applichiamo il CNOT non possiamo semplicemente
scambiare l'ordine ma invece dobbiamo applicare il gate X a entrambi i qubit e puoi verificare tutte queste relazioni da solo
se lo desideri pensando a cosa succede agli stati della base standard per esempio la situazione è simile per gli errori Z
tranne che i ruoli dei qubit di controllo e target si scambiano in particolare se eseguiamo un
gate Z sul qubit di controllo di un CNOT e poi eseguiamo il CNOT allora ha lo stesso effetto di eseguire il
gate Z dopo il CNOT ma se eseguiamo il gate Z sul qubit target invece allora è
equivalente a eseguire prima il CNOT e poi applicare un gate Z a entrambi i qubit e infine tutte queste
relazioni sono simmetriche nel senso che possiamo sempre scambiare l'ordine dei gate su entrambi i lati di ciascuna equazione
il che è equivalente a prendere l'inverso o il trasposto coniugato di entrambi i lati dato che i gate X Z e CNOT
sono tutti il proprio inverso ora consideriamo gli errori di phase flip e come possiamo rilevarli e correggerli
usando il codice Shore a 9 qubit ecco il nostro circuit di codifica e continueremo a pensare ai nove
qubit usati nella codifica come raggruppati in tre blocchi di tre qubit supponiamo che si verifichi un errore Z su
uno qualsiasi dei qubit come quello indicato qui usando ciò che abbiamo appena osservato sui gate Z
e sui gate CNOT ciò è equivalente a due errori Z prima del CNOT uno sul
controllo e uno sul qubit target e questi errori commutano con l'altro CNOT nel blocco quindi
possiamo scambiare l'ordine ed ecco cosa otteniamo l'errore Z inferiore non fa nulla perché agisce su uno stato
zero e possiamo far scorrere tutto il resto e ottenere questo diagramma quindi ciò che abbiamo trovato è che un errore Z da qualche parte all'interno
del blocco centrale è equivalente a un errore Z che si verifica sul qubit centrale prima della seconda fase di codifica e
puoi ragionare esattamente allo stesso modo per un errore Z su uno qualsiasi dei qubit una phase flip su qualsiasi qubit all'interno di un blocco
è equivalente a una phase flip sul corrispondente qubit prima della codifica interna e questo è in realtà abbastanza semplice e intuitivo se
pensi a come gli errori Z influenzano il codice a ripetizione a tre bit quindi un'opzione per gestire un errore Z
è decodificare il codice interno e poi rilevare e correggere gli errori Z usando il codice esterno che è la versione modificata
del codice a ripetizione a 3 bit che può correggere un errore Z in modo da correggere il nostro errore Z e
potremmo ri-codificare con il codice interno se volessimo farlo possiamo anche correggere gli errori Z
sul posto per così dire senza decodificare e poi ri-codificare ed è abbastanza semplice ma per spiegare come
possiamo farlo avremo bisogno di un po' più di spazio supponiamo di decodificare il codice interno
e poi calcoliamo la sindrome per il codice esterno usando lo stesso metodo di prima dove stiamo coinvolgendo solo i tre qubit dal codice esterno e
poi ri-codifichiamo bene possiamo semplificare tutti questi CNOT un po' e in effetti
possiamo usare le relazioni tra i gate NOT e i gate CNOT che abbiamo appena osservato poco fa per aiutare con quel
compito e facendo questo possiamo risparmiare quattro CNOT e questo è il circuit che otteniamo se si è verificato un errore Z su uno dei
qubit ciò che la sindrome ci dice ora non è quale qubit ha subito un errore Z ma piuttosto in quale blocco si è verificato l'errore Z
ma va bene perché sappiamo che non importa quale qubit all'interno di un blocco subisce un errore Z l'
effetto è lo stesso per tutti e tre i qubit all'interno di quel blocco e quindi possiamo in effetti correggere l'errore Z applicando un gate Z a uno qualsiasi dei
qubit all'interno di quel blocco questo tra l'altro è un esempio di quella che si chiama degeneracy in un codice di
correzione degli errori dove non identifichiamo in modo univoco un dato errore ma siamo comunque in grado di correggerlo infine supponiamo che si verifichino sia una
inversione del bit che una inversione di fase eventualmente sullo stesso qubit per esempio supponiamo che si verifichino una
inversione del bit e una inversione di fase su questo qubit qui come si scopre questi errori possono essere
rilevati e corretti completamente in modo indipendente e in effetti non importa se correggiamo prima ogni blocco per una
inversione del bit e poi correggiamo le phase flip o se lo facciamo nel senso contrario per vedere questo osserviamo prima
che l'ordine di questi errori non ha importanza quindi possiamo invertirli se vogliamo il motivo di ciò non è perché
X e Z commutano perché non lo fanno X * Z è uguale a negativo Z * X ma il
fattore meno 1 non ha effetto in questa situazione perché è una fase globale possiamo ora spostare l'errore Z proprio come
prima e a questo punto è evidente che se prima correggessimo ogni blocco per gli errori X e poi correggessimo
gli errori Z avremmo corretto entrambi gli errori in alternativa se per qualche motivo
decidessimo di correggere prima gli errori Z potremmo farlo e l'errore X non ha assolutamente alcun effetto in quel processo
questo deve essere vero perché primo l'errore X commuta con ogni singolo gate nel circuit che calcola la
sindrome per il codice esterno e secondo l'ordine tra l'errore X e il gate Z che applichiamo per fare la
correzione non ha importanza proprio come abbiamo argomentato quando il gate Z era un errore quindi ciò consente la correzione dell'errore Z
e possiamo poi correggere ogni blocco per eliminare l'errore X quindi quello che abbiamo argomentato è che possiamo
correggere un errore X un errore Z o entrambi su uno qualsiasi dei qubit usando questo codice
in effetti possiamo correggere più errori di così come più errori X a condizione che ricadano in blocchi diversi
o più errori Z a condizione che al massimo un blocco ne abbia un numero dispari ma andando avanti ciò che sarà più rilevante
è che possiamo correggere un errore X un errore Z o entrambi su qualsiasi qubit e nell'ultima parte della lezione
vedremo come questo sia in effetti sufficiente per concludere che questo codice può correggere un errore arbitrario su qualsiasi qubit
prima di passare all'ultima parte della lezione in cui considereremo errori quantistici arbitrari considereremo brevemente
le prestazioni del codice Shore a N qubit quando gli errori rappresentati dalle matrici di Pauli si verificano casualmente sui
qubit per essere più concreti consideriamo un semplice modello di rumore dove gli errori si verificano indipendentemente sui qubit
con ogni qubit che sperimenta un errore con probabilità p e senza correlazione tra gli errori su qubit diversi
lo scenario peggiore per il codice Shore a 9 qubit è che si verifichi un errore Y o in altre parole sia un errore X che un errore Z
su ogni qubit colpito e assumeremo questo scenario peggiore solo allo scopo di ottenere un limite
sulle prestazioni del codice ma potresti anche considerare per esempio che i tre errori di Pauli abbiano uguale
probabilità ora supponiamo che Q sia un qubit in un determinato stato che vorremmo proteggere dagli errori e immagina di
avere la possibilità di usare il codice Shore a 9 qubit dovremmo usarlo beh la risposta non è necessariamente
sì perché se c'è troppo rumore o in altre parole p è troppo grande usare il codice Shore potrebbe effettivamente peggiorare le cose
proprio come abbiamo visto per il codice a ripetizione quando p è maggiore di 1/2 ma se p è abbastanza piccolo allora la
risposta è sì dovremmo usare il codice quindi vediamo perché questo accade e cosa significa per p essere troppo grande o abbastanza piccolo
per questo codice il codice Shore può correggere qualsiasi errore di Pauli su un singolo qubit e nel caso peggiore
dove gli errori di Pauli sono errori Y ciò significa che il codice protegge con successo Q con una probabilità data dall'
espressione mostrata sullo schermo nello specifico il codice funziona quando non ci sono errori e ciò accade
con probabilità 1 meno p alla 9 perché ci sono nove qubit che devono essere ciascuno non colpiti e funziona quando c'è
esattamente un errore e considerando che ci sono nove qubit diversi che potrebbero potenzialmente essere colpiti ciò accade con probabilità 9 * P * (1 - p)^8
d'altra parte se non ci preoccupassimo di usare il codice il nostro unico qubit sarebbe indisturbato da un errore con
probabilità uno meno P quindi il codice aiuta solo quando la prima probabilità è maggiore della seconda
perché queste espressioni rappresentano le nostre probabilità di successo nei due casi quando usiamo il codice e quando
non lo usiamo ecco un grafico di queste due funzioni per valori piccoli di p e troviamo che il punto di pareggio si verifica a
circa 3 e 3/4 percento quindi se p è più piccolo di questo valore allora il codice
aiuta al punto di pareggio le probabilità sono uguali quindi stiamo solo sprecando il nostro tempo insieme a 8 qubit se
usiamo il codice ma altrimenti non c'è problema al riguardo e oltre quel punto non dovremmo assolutamente usare questo codice
perché sta effettivamente aumentando la probabilità di un errore sul qubit codificato a cui di solito ci riferiamo come il
qubit logico in questo contesto e ciò sta accadendo semplicemente perché la probabilità di due o più errori su nove qubit è
maggiore della probabilità di un errore su un singolo qubit per valori di p in questo intervallo 3 e 3/4 percento potrebbe non sembrare molto
soprattutto se confrontato con il 50% che è l'analogo punto di pareggio per il codice a ripetizione a tre bit per
le informazioni classiche ma è più difficile proteggere le informazioni quantistiche e inoltre sebbene questo
codice rappresenti una scoperta brillante come il primissimo codice di correzione degli errori quantistici ed è ottimo per scopi pedagogici il fatto
è che non è un codice poi così buono in termini pratici finora abbiamo considerato gli errori X
e gli errori Z nel contesto del codice Shore a 9 qubit ora consideriamo errori arbitrari
partendo prima dagli errori unitari quindi per esempio tale errore potrebbe corrispondere a una piccola
rotazione della sfera di Bloch che rappresenta forse un errore accumulato da un gate non perfetto per esempio
oppure potrebbe essere qualsiasi altra operazione unitaria su un qubit e non necessariamente qualcosa vicino all'operazione
identità potrebbe sembrare difficile correggere tali errori ci sono infiniti possibili errori come
questo ed è inconcepibile che potessimo in qualche modo identificare esattamente quale errore è e poi annullarlo ma
in realtà non dobbiamo fare nulla di diverso da ciò che abbiamo già discusso purché possiamo correggere un'inversione del bit una phase flip o entrambe allora
in effetti riusciremo a correggere un qualsiasi errore unitario su un singolo qubit e ora spiegherò perché
prima come tutte le matrici 2x2 possiamo esprimere una matrice unitaria arbitraria
che rappresenta un errore su un singolo qubit come combinazione lineare delle quattro matrici di Pauli inclusa la matrice
identità e tra l'altro come potresti aver notato sto usando X Y e Z maiuscole per denotare le matrici di Pauli non identità
e continuerò a farlo per il resto di questa serie è la convenzione nella correzione degli errori quantistici e rende anche
le cose un po' più facili da leggere in questo contesto sarà anche conveniente usare i pedici per indicare su quale
qubit agisce una data operazione unitaria su un qubit quindi per esempio se usiamo la convenzione di numerazione dei qubit di Qiskit
partendo dal qubit zero a destra allora abbiamo le espressioni mostrate sullo schermo per varie operazioni unitarie su singoli qubit dove in ciascun caso
effettuiamo il prodotto tensoriale della matrice unitaria con la matrice identità su ogni altro qubit quindi in particolare possiamo esprimere U_K che significa U applicato al qubit K come la stessa
combinazione lineare di prima tranne che ogni matrice di Pauli viene applicata al qubit K non è necessario preoccuparsi del
pedice per l'identità tra l'altro l'intendimento qui è che questa è l'identità su tutti i
qubit ora supponiamo che SI sia la codifica a 9 qubit di uno stato qubit se l'errore U avviene sul
qubit k allora otteniamo u_k * s che possiamo esprimere come combinazione lineare di operazioni di Pauli che agiscono su S che ovviamente
è solo s nel caso dell'identità a questo punto sarà utile osservare che la matrice di Pauli Y
è uguale a i * X * Z quindi possiamo fare quella sostituzione nella nostra
espressione quindi questo errore si è verificato e ora supponiamo di tentare di correggerlo usando la stessa procedura di
prima il primo passo è calcolare la sindrome che nel caso del codice Shore è lunga 8 bit due bit per ognuna delle
tre volte che usiamo il codice interno insieme a due bit aggiuntivi per il codice esterno ma in realtà non ha importanza possiamo semplicemente pensarci come una
stringa di lunghezza fissa ecco una descrizione dello stato che otteniamo appena prima della misurazione della sindrome dove ogni
sindrome è qualunque siano gli otto bit che otteniamo dall'errore di Pauli corrispondente nota a questo punto che i due
sistemi sono in genere correlati e questo è davvero la chiave per far funzionare tutto ciò misurando la sindrome ciò che
faremo effettivamente è collassare lo stato in uno in cui una delle quattro operazioni di Pauli è stata applicata al
qubit k di sì e sapremo dalla sindrome quale operazione di Pauli è stata quindi possiamo correggerla se
necessario in particolare se misuriamo la sindrome e facciamo la correzione appropriata allora otteniamo uno stato della
forma mostrata sullo schermo che in modo fondamentale è un prodotto stato abbiamo la nostra codifica originale non corrotta come
fattore tensoriale di destra che è ciò che è più importante qui e a sinistra abbiamo una matrice di densità s che
descrive una sindrome di errore casuale ma non c'è più alcuna correlazione con il sistema che ci interessa che è
quello a destra perché gli errori sono stati corretti a questo punto possiamo buttare via i qubit della sindrome o resettarli nel
caso volessimo usarli di nuovo e questo è in realtà abbastanza importante perché è così che la casualità o l'entropia
generate dagli errori vengono rimosse dal sistema ed è così che funziona la discretizzazione degli errori almeno per gli errori unitari
in sostanza misurando la sindrome proiettiamo efficacemente l'errore su un errore descritto da
una matrice di Pauli a prima vista potrebbe sembrare troppo bello per essere vero che possiamo correggere errori unitari arbitrari
in questo modo anche errori che sono piccoli e quasi impercettibili da soli ma ciò che è importante realizzare qui
è che questo è un errore unitario su un singolo qubit e per la progettazione del codice una singola operazione su un qubit non può cambiare lo stato
del qubit logico che viene codificato tutto ciò che può fare è spostare lo stato fuori dallo spazio delle codifiche valide
ma poi le correzioni lo riportano esattamente al punto in cui era infine consideriamo cosa accade
quando si verifica un errore arbitrario non necessariamente unitario la configurazione è la stessa di prima
abbiamo codificato un qubit in 9 usando il codice Shore e si verifica un errore arbitrario rappresentato da un canale qubit
su uno dei qubit come vedremo tutto andrà più o meno allo stesso modo
di quanto è andato per gli errori unitari e il primo passo verso la verifica di ciò è considerare una rappresentazione di Kraus del nostro
errore quello che possiamo fare ora è seguire esattamente lo stesso ragionamento dei casi degli errori unitari tranne che applichiamo quel
ragionamento alle matrici di Kraus piuttosto che a una singola matrice unitaria che rappresenta un errore
in particolare ogni matrice di Kraus può essere espressa come combinazione lineare di matrici di Pauli e questo ci consente di
esprimere l'azione di questo errore fi su qualunque qubit k capiti nel formato mostrato qui sullo
schermo quello che stiamo facendo è semplicemente espandere le matrici di Kraus come combinazioni lineari di matrici di
Pauli se poi calcoliamo e misuriamo la sindrome degli errori e correggiamo eventuali errori rivelati otterremo uno
stato simile a quello che avevamo nel caso di un errore unitario non entrerò nei dettagli è tutto abbastanza simile al caso unitario
e anche un po' più difficile da scrivere ma concettualmente parlando è abbastanza
semplice dovrei menzionare che tutto ciò si generalizza ad altri codici di correzione degli errori quantistici inclusi i codici che possono correggere errori su più
qubit in tal caso gli errori su più qubit possono essere espressi come combinazioni lineari di prodotti tensoriali di matrici di
Pauli e di conseguenza le diverse sindromi possibili descriveranno correzioni eseguite su più qubit invece che su uno solo
ma l'idea sottostante è esattamente la stessa ancora misurando la sindrome
proiettiamo o collapsiamo efficacemente gli errori in un insieme discreto di possibilità rappresentate da prodotti tensoriali
di matrici di Pauli e correggendo quegli errori ovvero gli errori di Pauli possiamo recuperare lo stato
codificato originale nel frattempo qualsiasi casualità generata nel processo viene spostata nei qubit della sindrome che possiamo poi
scartare o resettare il che è fondamentale perché è così che l'entropia generata dagli errori e dalle misurazioni della sindrome viene
rimossa dal sistema e questa è la fine della lezione in cui abbiamo dato un primo sguardo alla
correzione degli errori quantistici incluso il codice Shore a 9 qubit e la discretizzazione degli errori spero che ti unirai a me per la
lezione successiva in cui discuteremo il formalismo degli stabilizzatori che ci fornisce uno strumento potente per descrivere e
analizzare una classe ampia e interessante di codici di correzione degli errori quantistici inclusi quelli che sono candidati promettenti per
i computer quantistici reali arrivederci a presto
[Fine]